we make way for Gary Myers he is written
a book how about them Cowboys you know
you've been doing this a long time Gary
covering the NFL how many decades have
you been doing this
1978 was my first 1978 you gonna be in
this movie by the way no I'm not in this
movie oh no no no I wondered now they
made North Dallas 40 about the Cowboys
mm-hmm do you think that they would make
as popular as the Cowboys are you got in
you know the owner like you you got
everything that's could you make a
Cowboys movie well here's the deal you
know the title of the book is how about
them Cowboys obviously it goes back to
the Jimmy Johnson line you know I had a
little disagreement with my editor about
the title because I was saying you know
it it's so synonymous with Jimmy that
you know or the current day fans are the
ones that before gonna relate to it he
goes well do you have a suggestion and
because he didn't use my suggestion for
the book I'm offering it to you if you
produced the movie okay and I give total
credit to my wife okay
who is quite a great sense of humor
people told me she was a great sense of
humor because she married me okay but
the name that she suggested Jerry does
Dallas how perfect is that Wow Wow
okay you like it I do how about I get
Jon Voight to play Jerry Jones
that's good okay now I got the other who
is playing who's our guy from John C
McKinley could play Jason Garrett how
about that
the guy from scrubs and we're cast in
this we get John Krasinski in there John
look we can you become one of my
favorite actresses
okay we can be a little transition from
Jack Ryan but you know we can probably
find a spot maybe he could be the guy
who cleans Jerry Jones's glasses in the
suite I was thinking more in terms of
Jason Witten but oh if you think yeah I
think I'm wondering about that that you
know we make movies all the time and if
you're gonna play it to a fanbase there
although do we know how it would end
if we did a Cowboys movie been over 20
years I know
would not be a happy end all they had
this staying power as America's team
that was the initial premise of what I
was going on when I wrote this book when
I started doing my researches how is a
team that has been basically a 500 team
for 23 years how are they now worth five
billion dollars which is considerably
more than any other team
I think Manchester you is is second at
about four point one or two but they're
over a billion dollars more than the
Patriots who were second I think at
three point seven so how does that
happen and how are they more popular now
worldwide than they've ever been when it
doesn't make sense almost because
there's been no success yeah on the
field it's a phenomenon that I go back
to when they lost those back-to-back
championship games to the Lombardi
Packers and they were only a 6 or 7 year
old expansion team at that point and and
people just naturally gravitated to them
they were these this underdog but a
really appealing underdog and then stall
back came at the end of the 60s and then
the cheerleaders became a big deal and
they started winning championships and
they've just been able to sustain it
without the success which is amazing but
you have a guy who Jerry's is clearly a
great businessman but why can't he use
that same formula and well maybe he is
but he shouldn't be the general manager
no you let all the great dynasties
ownership a loud man you know coaches to
coach it feels like and it feels like he
still impedes the process but how can
you be a billionaire but not be a great
businessman as far as getting
performance on the field results well we
know he's in the Hall of Fame because of
what he's done to the economic economics
should he be in the Hall of Fame well if
you get a judge it by contributions to
the league then probably but if it's the
Hall of Fame really for
multimillionaires becoming multi
billionaires teaching multi millionaires
you know what he did around the league I
mean all these guys the team's Roger can
tell gonna get in the Hall of Fame
well Paul Tagliabue is not involved yeah
but I think that there's that owners had
a problem with Paul Tagliabue here's
Goodell who's taking the slings and
and made them money if we're looking at
contributions to the game I I'm
imagining this commissioner gets in
before the previous one yeah cuz I don't
think I don't necessarily think the
previous ones get it yet you know other
than keep this mind in 2020 which will
be the 100-year anniversary that they
get to celebrate for the league I hear
that they're going to expand it beyond
the five modern era candidates the two
contributors and the one senior and I
won't say they could open the floodgates
but they're gonna try to right some
wrongs of the past and have a much
bigger class in two years than they do
in a normal year so that could be the
opportunity well who's getting in that
you're hinting at well I'm talking about
taboo that's it I think that's the one
that the NFL was sort of embarrassed
about that all the the more than two of
the reasons that Paul's not in it was
one because the CBA that he signed as he
was walking out the door and he pushed
it through cuz he wanted to retire two
years later they they opted out of it
and then they wanted having a lockout
and then obviously is the concussion
situation you know which was whatever
reason was just pushed under the rug for
for many years but it wasn't like Paul
created it he did inherit it it was just
as bad or worse in the raziel years but
it just came to light during the ends of
the tagging booyah and and Rodger and
had it Rodger has tried to do things
here but they're fighting from so far
behind with all these former players who
having health problems that I'm not sure
they're gonna be able to clean it up
we're talking to Gary Myers the book is
how about them Cowboys available
everywhere I thought a Denzel Washington
for Michael Irvin what do you think oh
he would probably how about Michael B
Jordan that's a good one yeah we could
do that
what about Will Smith where do we work
him in Will Smith I'm from all my
favorite characters here now maybe it
could be on it I don't know somebody's
got to be Troy Aikman I may be Troy is
gonna be Troy may be Troy of either if
you could ask Jerry Jones one question
what's the answer you want that he has
to answer is how someone you were
alluding to before how is somebody who's
such an incredible
businessman have such a blind spot when
it comes to the football that he thinks
he can compete on the same level as say
the Ron Wolf's were in George Young and
Bill Polian and Bobby bethards I know he
knows more football than any owner in
the league and I do give him credit that
he played the game and he he's really
stayed up on it in any years before he
bought the Cowboys but he's just not
smart enough football wise true to run a
personnel department now to his credit
and I tell a story in the book about the
Johnny Manziel draft in 2014 I don't
know if you got to that one but it's
actually pretty funny that he was
outvoted everybody else in the room 2-1
and crazy on not want to take Manziel
and their list was three defensive
players Anthony Barr who went to the
Vikings Aaron Donald to once in a Rams
and Ryan shazier who went one spot ahead
of them to the Steelers and Steven Jones
was thinking all along we never even
didn't need to discuss Johnny Manziel
because they thought he was gonna be
picked way before the Cowboys were
picking so all of a sudden shazier goes
off the board and Steven kind of oh my
god I got a deal with my father now and
Jerry's going one by one around the room
you think we should take Manziel don't
know he'll fit perfectly in or out no
Jerry we can't do silly he's he's shut
out he's sitting there by himself and
say he's credited at least he didn't
force them to take Manziel although he
[ __ ] to moan about it and and Steven
was sitting right to his to his right
and as soon as they they calling the
legal office to call on Zack Martin who
turned it turned out to be a great
player Steven slat I mean Jerry slaps
Steven that so hard on the leg that kind
of reverberates around the room and he
gets in his ear and he says son let me
tell you something I didn't get to the
spot in my life by playing things down
in the middle and you just played it
down the middle and if that's the way
you're gonna run this team you're never
gonna be a success now Steven was hurt
by that because his father's his idol
you know fortunately for him he didn't
turn around and say to his father won't
tell me about the last 23 years
but Gerry never he never apologized him
about it but the fact that when Menzel
was cut by the Browns and Jerry never
won in and say hey we get a second shot
at this he never did that so that was
his way of saying hey you were right
you had an exchange and and I had heard
the same story and that is when Ezekiel
Elliott was in trouble that I was told
by a great source who said that Roger
Goodell the commissioner said to Jerry
Jones just don't say anything don't
don't you know let this just sort of
smooth over and he's not gonna get
suspend and that's why when Jerry found
out the Commissioner had suspended a
Zico Elliott he went ballistic he was
trying to derail his career I mean he
went all in and then you run and you you
print this but you find out from the
Commissioner the Commissioner comes up
to you after he finds out about this
story and says to you what well let me
just spin it back a little bit so the
night before Jerry's induction in the
Hall of Fame he has this 8
million-dollar party with Justin
Timberlake and one of the invited guests
was Roger Goodell who five days later
would call Jerry in Oxnard California to
break the news that he's suspending
Elliott for six games and Jerry says
don't do that you know that's the wrong
thing to do but anyhow at the party
Jerry is standing there with a drink in
his hand with Bon Jovi and Roger and I I
write in there that Roger was there
drinking on Jerry's dime knowing he had
his he had the decision made at that
point he just didn't want to ruin
Jerry's Hall of Fame weekend so I have a
great picture in the book of the three
of them staying there having a drink and
the caption is that Jerry Jones was just
living on a prayer if he thought Roger
Goodell
and wasn't getting suspended suspend
Elliott so I help it's a league meetings
in March in it was in Orlando this year
I had my final interview with Jerry and
that's how current this book is I mean I
was able to get stuff in from that
period of time so I'm sitting with him
in a conference room and I said Jerry
you've alluded to me three times already
there's somebody really high up in the
legal office assured you that zyg
Elliott was not going to be suspended
but you wouldn't
name who was I said listen it was Raj it
wasn't yeah it was okay so he admits it
was Roger yeah we knew it but I got him
on the record saying it yeah
so now good for you a half hour later
Raj is holding his end of the league
meetings press conference now I've known
Roger since 1981 and we have been
friends over the years and but that has
never interfere with me asking the tough
questions or ripping him for the Ray
Rice or anything and he knows that and
and that's one of the things I've
admired about Rogers like was able to
really really critical in the paper of
him and he would never he wouldn't he
would never call me about it and he it
wouldn't affect our relationship
whatsoever so I get him in the hallway
after that his news conference I said
Roger I just came from the meeting with
Jerry who's insisting that you not
anybody else but you told them that Zig
Elliot was not going to be suspended I
said is that true and he looks at me and
he goes the answer is no in period o
period is there something about that you
don't understand I'm thinking go on go
on get the messenger but if you want to
blame me that's fine
maybe you should have corrected his
punctuation the end period oh here maybe
just a no period that could have set him
off a little bit more - but I was told
the same thing that he said - Jer that's
why Jerry went apoplectic here yeah on
the commissioner because he was told
don't worry just don't say anything and
then Jerry had a whole lot to say after
that well as recently as that Friday
afternoon of hall-of-fame weekend Jerry
had a little press conference in which
he was insisting once again that Zeke
would not be suspended you know I mean
insisting and you had to figure somebody
was telling all right the book is how
about them Cowboys or it could have been
Jerry does dallas that'll be for the
movie and you know we have a spot for
you in that you do yeah I haven't quite
figured out what it is okay maybe
Stephen Jones I want to get you a big
part in them hmm does Stephen Jones so
when when Jay
he steps down who takes over well it
it's already been decided that a third
of the team will go to Stephen a third
to Charlotte and a third to Jerry jr.
and that Stephen because he's the oldest
and has been with Jerry since day one in
1989 with with the Cowboys Stephen will
have the league vote now the really
interesting thing to me Dan is whether
or not Stephen has learned from his
father's mistake and will name a general
manager Stephen is very involved in
personnel now but if he's gonna be
running this team on a day-to-day basis
he has to learn and he has to know that
the reason that the Cowboys hadn't been
in Super Bowl since 95 is because once
Jimmy left and left barry switzer a team
to win a Super Bowl with that they've
never been able to replenish the
personnel and he also had a great quote
in there well it's from Troy Aikman
where you know Troy and Jimmy you know
choice yeah we could have been Brady and
Belichick I was the best quote in the
entire yeah other than in period no
period yeah I mean I was talking to
Jimmy and he he said that and this is
relatively recent that that Troy made
that comment they were having a beer and
you know Troy it could have been anybody
but Barry Switzer and Troy would have
been better with it he still was upset
that Jimmy left but he hated Switzer you
know going back to the Oklahoma days
industry having a transfer but so
they're sitting around maybe three four
years ago and and Jimmy has no regrets
to whatsoever I said you would have been
in the Hall of Fame already you would
have won four in a row don't you care
about that he goes no my primary goal in
life is just to be happy and I wasn't
happy I couldn't stand be in there
anymore so Troy says to him you know we
you know we could have been Brady and
Belichick and I said to Jimmy what was
your reaction he says and they would
have been they would have said to
standard so high set the bar so high
that Brady and Belichick never would
have been able to jump over that one
good stuff Gary has always and we've
come to expect that the book is how
about them Cowboys written by Gary Myers
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]